ce sont des périmètres dit de
circulation le premier est un périmètre
d'interdiction de circulation c'est
qu'on interdit la circulation pourquoi
ben parce qu'on considère que pour des
par mesure de sécurité hein donc c'est
une zone de sécurité j'y reviendrai
c'est très important de comprendre ça
c'est un périmètre où on restreint la
circulation pourquoi parce que il y a
énormément de de flux de piétons qui
parce qu'ils se rendent au site de
compétition qui parce qu'ils se rendent
à la cérémonie d'ouverture qui parce
qu'ils se rendent voir une course de de
cycliste vont emprunter ces rues en flux
piétonnier et puis il y a aussi un du
passage motorisé puisque il y a tous les
véhicules du cojot les livreurs les
prestataires voilà ce sont des zones où
il y aura une circulation à la fois déjà
assez dense avec l'organisateur et puis
des flux de piéton très dense avec un
risque important et j'insi c'est un
périmètre de sécurité avec un risque
important de voitures bélier Si on ne
faut procédait pas des contrôles très
clairement bon donc ce périmètre est un
périmètre par principe d'interdiction de
circulation dans la vraie vie quand on
en fait des manifestations à Paris on
prévoit aussi toujours ces périmètres de
circulation pendant la coupe du monde de
rugby il y avait ces périmètres de
circulation ils existaient sauf que la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est l'espace
d'un match c'est un petit peu moins long
là on parle de sites de compétition qui
vont parfois être activés tous les jours
pendant 15 jours bon et puis ensuite il
y a la scène la séquence des
paralympiques qui V vont se dérouler à
peu près sur les mêmes scènes